Just because many screenwriters, directors
and stars are way to the left
doesn't mean that films with libertarian themes
and messages don't get made.
Here are 5 great movies made over the past
25 years that any libertarian will enjoy.
This Pixar film directed by Brad Bird is so
full of speeches
extolling individualism, personal greatness
and self fulfillment,
it sometimes sounds like it was scripted by
Ayn Rand.
You sly dog, you got me monologuing, I can't
believe it.
In fact Rand is clearly part of the inspiration
for the character of Edna Mode.
No capes!
The libertarianism of the film exists on at
least two levels:
one obvious and one a little more hidden.
But even the super villain in The Incredibles
is a creature of self invention and self improvement.
While the Incredibles are born with their
powers,
Syndrome is a normie who worships Mr Incredible
and is desperate to be his side kick.
I know all your moves, favorite crime fighting
style, favorite catch phrases, everything!
I am your number one fan!
When Mr Incredible dismisses young Buddy,
he uses that disillusionment to fire his ambitions
to create weapons and powers via innovative
technology.
Like an animated version of Richard Nixon,
syndrome's ambitions ultimately get the best of him.
I mean, after all, I am your biggest fan.
But he just may be the real hero of the movie,
at least for those of us without naturally
occurring super powers.
The Incredibles are returning after a 14 year
hiatus with a sequel hitting theaters in June.
So we'll see them again soon.
French Canadian director Denys Arcand's brilliant
sequel to The Decline of The American Empire
is the single best depiction of the depredations
of socialized medicine.
The healthcare system in the movie is so sclerotic,
that the movie's protagonist, a retired academic
named Remy,
cannot even score the drugs he needs to commit
suicide,
until his estranged banker son buys them on
the black market.
Even more disturbing is the moment when the
terminally ill Remy
and his former university colleagues
admit that their intellectual faddishness
led them to embrace every awful left wing
ism of the past 30 years
despite their often massive human toll.
None of those drugs have been approved by
the FDA.
Screw the FDA, I'm gonna be DOA.
This based on a true story movie about a rodeo
rider and a drag queen
riding around the US Food and Drug Administration
brought home Oscars not just for it's two
leads,
but the film's makeup artist who reportedly
worked on a budget of just 250 dollars.
Set in the 1980s Matthew McConaughey plays
Ron Woodroof
a boozy roughneck who is given 30 days to
live after being diagnosed with AIDS.
Faced with such a death sentence, he schools
himself on a wide variety of treatments
first in Mexico and then all over the world.
With the help of a cross dressing party girl
named Rayon,
Woodroof skirts FDA prohibitions against importing,
using and selling unapproved drugs
by creating a buyer's club in which members
pay a monthly membership
and assume all risks.
I'm afraid that you are nothing more than
a common drug dealer,
so if you'll excuse us, we would like to-
Oh I'm the drug dealer?
No you're the fuckin' drug dealer, I mean
goddamn people are dying!
The depiction of indifference to patient's
suffering
and bureaucratic quashing of medical freedom
even for people who are certain to die is
unsparing, deeply moving and totally inspirational.
Especially now that even Donald Trump has
endorsed right to try legislation
that would allow terminally ill patients access
to non approved medicines.
My name's Joy by the way.
Jennifer Lawrence became a mega star
playing the anti government rebel Katniss
Everdeen in the Hunger Games movies.
And while there's no shortage of libertarian
sentiment coursing through that trilogy,
it's actually a quieter movie starring Lawrence
that fully embodies libertarian virtues
of hard work, commercial innovation and dogged
entrepreneurship.
In Joy, Lawrence plays real life Miracle Mop inventor
Joy Mangano
who helped make cleaning your floors a little
bit easier and better
while becoming wealthy at the same time.
The film is nothing less than a paean to capitalism's
genius at allowing self expression.
As the story begins, Joy is supporting a wide
variety of family layabouts
while barely making ends meet.
But she's firm with her daughter about what
really counts.
In a dramatic scene with Bradley Cooper who
plays an executive at a home shopping network,
Joy summarizes in a few sentences
what it took Joseph Schumpeter, Friedrich
Hayek and Milton Friedman whole books to say.
You said to me that David Selznick the son
of immigrants
married Jennifer Jones an all American girl
from Oklahoma
because in America all races and all classes
can meet and make whatever opportunities they can
and that is what you feel when you reach into
people's homes with what you sell.
As former Reason editor Virginia Postrel wrote
of Joy:
The film acknowledges the wealth creating
value of incremental improvements
even in the most mundane items.
When it was first released in 1984,
Ghostbusters quickly became the most successful
comedy in film history.
In many ways the film was perfectly in sync
with the Reagan revolution's valorization
of business and demonization of government.
You've never been out of college, you don't
know what it's like out there.
I've worked in the private sector, they expect
results.
Ghostbusters begins with a team of paranormal
investigators
getting kicked out of Columbia university
for, well,
being bullshit artists.
They're forced to start their own risky business
venture,
filling what they believe is an undeserved
market niche.
We're ready to believe you!
Even though New York is literally being invaded
by evil spirits,
the true villain of the movie is not the otherworldly
demon Gozer,
but an Environmental Protection Agency bureaucrat
named Walter Peck.
I want this man arrested!
Captain these men are in criminal violation
of the Environmental Protection Act
and this explosion is a direct result of it.
Your mother!
But of course the Ghostbusters ultimately
persevere, save the city
and turn a good buck in the process.
We're gonna have to ask you for four big ones,
4000 dollars for that,
but we are having a special this week on proton
charging...
Well what do you think?
That was totally wicked!
It's by no means an exhaustive list,
so add your personal favorites in the comments.
And don't forget to tell us just how wrong
we are either.